>> Sharon Horowitz:
Good afternoon.
Welcome to the African and
Middle Eastern Reading Room.
On behalf of the music division
and the Hebraic section,
let me thank you all for
coming to today's program.
My name is Sharon Horowitz.
I'm a reference librarian
in the Hebraic section.
The Hebraic section marks
its beginning in 1912
with the receipt of 10,000
Hebrew books and pamphlets,
whose purchase was
made possible by a gift
from New York philanthropist,
Jacob Schiff.
From those humble beginnings,
our collections have grown
to around 250,000 items in
Hebrew, Yiddish, Ladino,
Judeo-Persian, and other
Hebraic-script languages.
The Hebraic section also
includes an important collection
of books in Ge'ez, Hark
[phonetic], and Tigrinya,
the languages of
Ethiopia, past and present.
Our sections' holdings are
particularly strong in the areas
of bible and Rabbinics, liturgy,
Hebrew language and literature,
[inaudible] and Jewish history.
Two of our missions
in this division are
to publicize our collections
and to bring people
into the library.
One way we accomplish
this second goal is
by holding lectures
and having programs
such as the one we are
hosting here today.
And now, a word about
our speaker.
Vivi Lachs is a social
and cultural historian,
a performer as well
as an academic.
She completed her PhD in 2015
from Royal Holloway
University of London.
She has given many academic
presentations focused
on ethnomusicology
and the acculturation
of Jewish immigrants
to English life.
She has written both
academic and popular articles
and has performed
throughout Europe.
She has a wide experience
performing
as a Yiddish vocalist,
dance leader,
and among her
performance-related
accomplishments, she has
organized a marching band
and chorus performing
Yiddish songs of protest
from the late 19th Century by
the late Morris Winchevsky.
Vivi has been called the Yiddish
London folk song detective.
She collects, performs,
translates
and records Yiddish
songs about London.
In her book, White Chapel
Noise, Jewish immigrant life
and Yiddish song and
verse, London 1884 to 1914,
Ms. Lachs researched
points to the similarities
between these Yiddish folk
songs and English musical songs.
Layers of cultural references
in the Yiddish text are closely
analyzed and quoted to draw
out the complex, yet intimate
histories they contain,
offering new perspectives
on Anglo-Jewish histography
in three main areas.
Politics, sex, and religion.
Two items of business,
before we begin.
Vivi Lachs' book, White Chapel
Noise, will be available
for sale after the program, and
she will be happy to sign books,
and this event is
being videotaped
for subsequent broadcasting.
There will be a formal
question and answer period
after the lecture, at which
the audience is encouraged
to ask questions
and offer comments.
Please be advised that your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcast
as part of this event.
By participating in the
question and answer period,
you are consenting to the
library's possible reproduction
and transmission
of your remarks.
And now, please join me in
welcoming Dr. Vivi Lachs.
[applause]
>> Vivi Lachs: I've
just [inaudible].
Thank you very much, Sharon.
It's lovely to be here
in this amazing building,
which I haven't been in before.
I mean, obviously I've been
in the British library many,
many times, so I know
exactly what people do
in these sort of buildings.
So, I'm going to tell you
a little bit about my book
and hopefully entertain
you with it
and give you some ideas
from what it's about.
So the book is called
White Chapel Noise,
and the White Chapel is
an area of East London.
It's in the East End where
the immigrant population came
to from the mid-1880s.
So Jewish immigrants
from Eastern Europe came
over to White Chapel,
and they spoke Yiddish,
and that Yiddish culture
just infused the area
in this time from the mid-1880s.
And this is a picture from 1897,
and it's showing the
noise that's going on.
And by noise, I don't
just mean the hubbub.
I don't just mean the sort
of like the horses' hooves
and the whirring of wheels
and the new motor cars.
It's people talking and people
shouting and people arguing
and people crying and
laughing and all that.
But in particular, the noise
is people having arguments
with each other because there
were huge arguments going
on at this time.
And one of the big issues for
all of these people was how
to acculturate to
English society.
Because they came
from Eastern Europe,
and the culture was
very, very different,
and they wanted obviously
to become English.
Not only did they, the
immigrants, come over and want
to be English, but also the
settled Jewish communities,
who had been there for
some decades already,
they really wanted these
immigrants to become English
because they were a source
of acute embarrassment
to the Jewish community for
these very poor immigrants
to come along when they
as a middle class society
had got Jewish emancipation,
and they wanted to hold onto
the gains that they'd made.
So, the book is, it's in
two parts, essentially,
and the first part gives
you some contextual history.
So the first part gives you
two particular histories.
Firstly, it lays out the
labor history of the time,
and it looks at the radicals
or the socialists
and the anarchists.
However, the particular
difference
in this history is it's looking
at the way poetry was used
as a strategy by the socialists.
The second history
is the history
of the Cockney Yiddish musical
as it was rather
affectionately known.
And this is the musical
in Yiddish
in the east end of London.
And then, the second part
of the book is analysis
of what are called Kuplatan
[phonetic] couplets.
And these couplets come from
three genres, socialist poetry,
music-hall song,
and satirical verse,
which I'll tell you
about in a minute.
There are three overarching
perspectives that cut
across this, and I've
just looked at the idea
of anglicization of people
wanting to become English.
The second large perspective
is that of transnationalism.
So although I chose material
that is very much about London
and about England, in fact,
it's also about a much wider
Yiddish-speaking world.
And the third one is the culture
controversy, is the noise
of the argument of the
[foreign language spoken]
and the shouting and
the crying and those,
it's what were they arguing
about, what was going on there.
And then the themes,
politics, sex, and religion.
You might think have been
written about quite a lot
but not from these sources
because from taking things
from Yiddish is, first of
all, there's been a lot
of Anglo-Jewish history
written, very,
very few Yiddish
sources have been used.
So using those sources, you
get a very different view.
But secondly, the source I've
chosen are from popular culture.
And if you're taking
sources from popular culture,
you're getting a
view from below,
and you're really getting
into those arguments.
So you're not getting
the official line.
You're not getting minutes of
synagogue meetings or various,
not they weren't arguments
in synagogue meetings,
but you are getting the things
that people are making fun of.
And if you look at what
people are making fun of,
you can see actually what's
really touching people,
especially the satirists.
So, I'll start up
with the three genres.
The first one is socialist
poetry, and I found this
in all sorts of publications.
So we have the newspapers, the
Polish Yid or The Polish Jew,
[foreign language spoken],
The Worker's Friend.
We have pamphlets.
For example, the one in the
top middle, I don't know
if anyone can read that,
Mary [inaudible] you read it.
>> This Vetting System.
>> Vivi Lachs: This
Vetting System.
So, we've got, so pamphlets
about politics going on,
and then we've got
song sheets as well,
like Yiddish [foreign language
spoken], which is a serious
of Yiddish freedom, which is
a series of different songs.
So this is, and I've
found lots and lots
and lots of this material.
I'll tell you how
many in a minute.
The second genre
is musical songs.
And these were produced in
song sheets and song books.
So at the top left
you'll see a song sheet,
so this is a little bit
of a tattered one there.
That's from the National
Library of Israel.
In the middle you see a
program, a theater program,
which has got a cross-dressed
actress on the front.
On the bottom right,
you have a song book
which tells us there are
150 pages and 100 songs.
Actually they can't count, there
are 102 songs in that book.
And that was because
it was pulling lots
of pamphlets together, which
is sort of what they did.
And there are some pages
from that at the bottom.
So these are all the songs
that were being song,
and when we start getting
into them, we can have a bit
of a laugh and possibly a bit
of a cry as well over them.
And finally, the third
genre is satirical verse,
and people were writing
satirical verse everywhere.
Satire is a fantastic genre
to look at for a historian,
because although you have
to go digging a bit to find
out actually what's going on
there, you really get to see
where people are really
like having a punisher,
of having a go at each other.
So, what I'm going to do is
I'm going to have a look at all
of these three perspectives
and show you where they come
in to a couple of texts.
So I've mentioned
Anglicization, Transnationalism,
and the cultural noise,
and now I'm going to look
at two different texts.
The first one is a poem
by Morris Winchevsky,
who we'll come across a
little bit later, again,
and this is a poem
called London bay nakht.
And I'll start off
by looking at it.
In fact, I'll start off
by singing it to you.
How about that?
And then we'll have a
look at what's going on.
So it's about street lights.
[ Singing ]
And it goes on so all the
things that the streetlights see
and the streetlights don't see.
So they don't see, they see
the streets, but they don't,
and the walls of the buildings,
but they don't see the
unemployment and the poverty
and the homelessness,
and the difficulty
of being a new immigrant
in the city.
And the song then
compares these streetlights
to the London committee
and the London committee
who were the Jewish board
of guardians were people
who were supporting
the immigrants.
However, what you'll see is
there's a line that goes,
have you seen a greener
Jew wandering alone.
In verse two, the last line of
that verse, too new an immigrant
to be helped by the
London committee,
and that too new an immigrant
is because the London Board
of Guardians wouldn't support
immigrants until they'd been
in Britain for six months.
So if you came to Britain
and you didn't have a job
and you didn't have family
there and you didn't have a way
of keeping yourself, then in
fact, you would have fallen
into a huge poverty gap because
there would be no support
for you on an institutional
level.
So, looking at that
content, it's very,
very much about England
and about Anglicization
because it's engaging
with English culture
and English [inaudible].
However, there's also a very
interesting transnational part
of this, and that is this poem
was written by Winchevsky,
who wasn't really a poet
when he was writing this.
He was just a beginning
poet, and he wrote this
in the structure of a poem
by Mietlev [phonetic],
who was a Russian poet,
and Mietlev wrote a poem
called Fonarichi [phonetic],
Street Lights.
And Mietlev's poem also had
street lights see some things
and don't see other things.
The things they saw though,
the things they didn't see
that were sort of hidden to
the street lights were a couple
in love, a woman who's
just been abandoned.
They were things that
were socially important,
but they weren't
politically important,
and so Winchevsky came along
and threw a punch behind it,
putting some political
importance to this.
So, in a way that was a
criticism of Mietlev's poem,
but it also like
gave him a structure
to write a better poem too.
The other things
that's transnational
about this that's very
interesting is this poem was
published in New York, but you
couldn't really publish a poem
in New York called
London bay nakht.
I mean who was going to read it?
So they changed the name of it
to [foreign language
spoken] street lights.
And they couldn't really
have the London committee.
So that was changed to [foreign
language spoken] street light.
The New York Eighth Street folk,
which is on the lower east side.
The interesting thing about this
is that if you can have a poem
or a song that is written
and published and performed
in Britain and then in a
completely different place
in New York, you can
make some claim to saying
that the experience in
both these places is very,
very similar.
So we have a transnational
culture of immigrants going
to different places and actually
absorbing the same popular
culture, being given that
same popular culture.
I also look at one other
song that also engages
with these different
transnationalism cultural
controversy and Anglicization.
And this one, I'm
actually only going
to look particularly
and Anglicization.
And that is that term Cockney
Yiddish that's used and just try
and describe what
Cockney Yiddish is.
Now, first of all in
the transnational front,
this is a song called
[foreign language spoken].
It's rather a curious
Yiddish name.
I'm not going to go into that at
the moment, that's in the book,
but I will say is that the
original [foreign language
spoken] was written by a man
called Abraham Goldsfaden,
and Goldsfaden was a father
of the Yiddish theater.
Now, he wrote this
about a decade before
or actually probably more, and
this was written around 1900's.
It was probably written in
about 1880 by Goldsfaden,
and Goldsfaden's song,
everybody would have known,
people loved Goldsfaden.
So if you produce a song
in London with a title
that everyone knows, everyone's
already got some expectations,
so they sort of know
what's going to happen.
Now the Goldsfaden's song is
about a tired, dispirited Jew
who is wandering around
looking for a homeland,
this archetypal figure
of the wandering Jew,
and his answer is,
[foreign language spoken],
go back to the Jewish
homelands of Zion.
The [foreign language spoken]
in London is not saying
anything of the sort.
But that also has an
archetypal Jew that's wandering
around homeless and penniless,
but what the [foreign
language spoken] the world
to go back is Eastern Europe.
So it's a curious poem that
again, a song that really
like is part of British
culture and talks about Britain.
But let's have a look
at the Cockney Yiddish.
Git a blik in der leyn vet
interest rate dort zen file
mentshn shteyen aropgelozt
demonstrate kop.
Tsvishn zey in dermit
in der korner goldston strit
shteyt a griner yid un kukt oys
a dzhob.
So we've got a few words here
in fact, but particularly,
the first line git
a blik in der leyn,
der leyn was Petticoat
Lane, which was the market.
Okay. But of course you're
going to use a word like leyn.
You wouldn't change that,
but we've got in der--
I'm sorry, what am I knocking--
we've got in der korner
of goldston strit.
Well the words for corner
in Yiddish [foreign
language spoken].
It's not korner.
Korner is an English word.
And so they're throwing
in an English word
for no particular reason really.
Have another look
at the next verse.
A yolk hot bald derkent az
a griner dort gayt un hot
oysgetsoygn zayne hent un
hot im bavelkomt mit a fayt.
So here you can see quite
clearly there's lots of words
for welcome in Yiddish.
[Foreign language spoken]
is not a Yiddish word.
It's an English word being
Yiddish-sized by putting a sort
of Yiddish inflection on it.
The word fight is also
not a Yiddish word.
It's an English word,
and in fact,
the word [foreign language
spoken], which it rhymes
with is changed from gayts
to giyts to make it rhyme,
which is a different way
of pronouncing the Yiddish.
So this sort of Englishness
creeping
into the songs makes
them very much
as a part of English culture.
So, I'm now going to talk about
the themes of politics, sex,
and religion, and I'm going to
give you a couple of example
on each of them by looking at
a couple of different songs
and get a sense of what
we can sort of glean
from the history in these songs.
So we're going to stay
with Morris Winchevsky,
who wrote a poem called
Akhdes, and this poem, Akhdes,
became very popular later.
It became a very popular poem,
and in fact in the
1920's it was made
into a song called
[foreign language spoken].
Some of you might have heard--
[ Singing ]
So, but that was
a completely song.
The [foreign language
spoken] is a nice happy,
clappy song that they claim
came from the Winchevsky.
Winchevsky's poem is a satire.
It's very funny, but
it's not happy clappy.
And we'll have a
look at the poem
and see what it's telling us.
So the poem says,
we are all united.
Whether we've got
a lot or a little.
We all pray from the
same prayer book.
We're all united whether
we're cutting coupons
or we're cutting trousers.
I mean whether you're poor
or rich, we're all united.
We're all united whether
you've got short [inaudible],
the sidecurls, the [inaudible]
and other groups have
or whether we've got long ones,
or whether we put
them behind our ears
or whether we have
them hanging straight.
Whether we're hungry or
whether we're satisfied,
we're all united just like all
these things that are united.
But when you look at
it a bit more closely,
you say well actually
what's going on there
because there's something
very specific going on here.
Winchevsky is writing in London.
He was in London for 15 years,
and he's writing about politics.
So, first of all, anyone
recognize this chap?
Karl Marx.
Karl Marx was the inspiration
to many of the socialists,
and his famous line about unity
was workers of the world unite.
It's particular important
because what Winchevsky
is saying in his poem is
that actually it's not workers.
No, the aristocracy and
the workers are united.
It's very antisocialist because
what Winchevsky is saying
and the socialists say is
the unity does not come
from ethnicity.
Just because you all happen to
be Jews, that creates no unity.
The unity is across class,
and it doesn't matter
what religion you are.
So, in that sense, we can see
that what this is going to do
as soon as he has a poem called
united, we know it's going
to turn everything on its head.
We all pray from the same
prayer book is a phrase,
we all sing from the same hymn
sheet, but actually he's using
that phrase but being
quite clever about it.
A month prior to this poem being
written was the publication
of the Single's Pray Book.
And the Single's Prayer
book was published
for the Anglo-Jewish
community who were established
in middle class, and
they spoke English.
The immigrants largely
didn't speak English,
they spoke Yiddish.
So a brand-new translation,
beautiful as it was,
and a really important new
addition to Anglo-Jewish
and Anglo-Jewish orthodoxy
wasn't particularly a very
useful addition to
the immigrants
so they certainly
didn't create unity.
So we're also united if
you're cutting trousers
or you're cutting coupons.
Well cutting trousers means
that you are what most Jews
in the East End were at this
time, a large percentage worked
in sweatshops as tailors
[foreign language spoken].
So, these people,
they're cutting trousers,
they're being manufacturers,
they're using their
hands and producing.
Cutting coupons refers
to the Jewish [inaudible]
guardians giving handouts.
So they, later on they gave
money, but at this stage,
in fact two years after
this had changed to money,
so we can really see
how much it was topical
that this time they're
giving coupons.
So the socialists are
saying don't take handouts.
That is not the way
to be a worker.
The way to be a worker is
to work with your hands
and to be a part of
the working class.
Finally, using the word unity
is particularly important
because six months
before this, there was a,
six months before this the
chief rabbi, Nathan Adler, died,
and there was a lot of talk
about who was going to take over
and where they would live and
what sorts of position they'd do
and what they'd be involved
in, and under the title
that was the letters page,
unity not uniformity.
And under that title, there
were lots and lots and lots
of letters about what was going
to happen, and it's almost
like Winchevsky in his
poem, he's adding to that.
This is his contribution.
Those letters were produced
in the Jewish chronicle.
Winchevsky's letter was produced
in the [foreign language
spoken], The Worker's Friend,
but essentially it is if you
like his contribution
to that debate.
So when you look at a song like
this, you can see all the layers
of satire, and then when
you sing, when you go back
and sing [foreign language
spoken], again, you can bear
in mind that it comes from
a good strong history.
Morris Winchevsky, in terms
of strategy for the poetry,
so we saw earlier on that he
wrote a poem called London bay
nakht, which was part of what
was called London [inaudible].
He wrote another poem called
[foreign language spoken],
Three Sisters, about
three girls in poverty.
One's selling shoelaces.
One is selling flowers.
And the other is
selling herself.
And he puts a socialist message
by the girls not blaming each
other but blaming society,
by blaming devout and
[foreign language spoken].
They blame the society for them
having to do this sort of work
because of their poverty.
So these are poems about
terrible properties
and getting people
to feel something.
The poem that we have
about London bay nakht
as well was also about
people in poverty.
Then we have the satirical
poem, but he had other poetry
that he wrote as well.
And this is one called
Tsum arbayter fraynd.
And as you see from the lyrics,
this is really socialist
polemic.
It's about alienation.
People who are producing are
not the same people who consume.
So, I'm going to
sing you one verse.
[ Singing ]
It's particularly interesting in
terms of the melody of the song
because [foreign language
spoken] who was a Yiddish sort
of like critic and
writer came across girls
in a factor singing this song.
This is actually a picture
of a factory in Leeds,
but he came across girls
singing this song in a factory
in Belarus, and this
is what he said.
He said the tune was
haunting, solemn and haunting.
The machines knocked and
the song carried, demanded,
punished, and welcomes
the arbayter fraynd.
I heard this song many
times in the factories.
It was sung heartily
and with feeling.
At times, a factory girl
would get a tear in her eye,
but after they finished
singing the atmosphere,
it was continuously oppressive,
would simply become cleansed.
So another strategy that
he has was to create songs
that were going to help people
through the day, that were going
to encourage them to keep going.
And finally, the sort of songs
he wrote were also hymns to go
out onto the streets for
union action and to march the
in di gasn, tsu di masn.
Fun badrikte feltker-rasn
ruft der frayhaytsgayst.
Ikh bring vafn far dem shlafn.
Ikh bafray di arbet-shklafn
un ikh makh zey drayst.
So they're out there chanting
and singing the songs,
and again, they refer to
things that are going on,
in particular strike
action in London.
So Albert [inaudible] asking
for systematic work was
because they wanted
to end out work,
which meant that
people would take work
in and cut union rates.
And also [foreign
language spoken]
because on these strikes
they weren't solely strikes
from the Jewish tailors or the
Jewish shoe and bootmakers,
but they were actually strikes
where the non-Jewish dockers,
the English dockers were
also, and the Irish dockers,
were also coming
in to join them.
So, moving on now
to the theme of sex.
And I found about
80 musical songs,
and out of those 80 musical
songs that mentioned London,
around 47 of them mentioned sex.
Now, you might say, that's
obvious in the musical
because let's have a
look at this picture
that we've got in front of us.
On the stage, we have a very
stereotyped Jewish man and woman
who looked like they're in
a [foreign language spoken]
or in a very sort of stereotyped
version of the [inaudible].
Up in the gallery, we've
got some rather drunken lads
who clearly aren't being
terribly entertained
by what's on the stage.
The orchestra seems to me
not keeping very good time,
and instead of sitting on chairs
as one would in the theatre,
the front row is full of beds
that people are camoodling
[phonetic] on.
Now this is a satirical cartoon
that's on the front cover
of a journal called [foreign
language spoken], the blofer.
It was produced between 1911
and 1913, and all the things,
you know, obviously you take
satire with a pinch of salt,
but there's always
an element of truth.
But not everyone is writing
silly songs for the music call
to entertain those lads.
Some of the songs are actually
very, very moving songs,
and this song by Joseph
Markevitch tells a story
of a woman in Eastern Europe
who has been abandoned
by her husband.
He comes over to
London, and he disappears
into the 150,000 immigrants
that are in the streets
of London's east end, and she's
writing to him, getting more
and more upset, saying,
you know, help me,
we need help, and
the chorus goes--
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
And what you'll find
is that everyone
in the audience would
have been in tears.
They would have been crying
because they all knew
people like this.
They knew people that
were abandoned in Russia.
were abandoned in Britain
as their husbands came
over here and disappeared
into a much larger low east side
or anywhere else
those immigrants came
to in the U.S. However,
most of the songs
that were being performed
in the music hall were pretty
much geared towards those lads
in the audience, and one
of these songs was a song called
Vus geyst nisht aheym sore-gitl.
Does that sound familiar
to anyone?
Won't you Come Home.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
There we go, how does it go?
Won't you come home girl, baby?
Won't you come home?
[ Singing ]
So, it's, I mean, you
know, this is a known song,
and it was a known song in 1905.
So, but hang on a second,
this is slightly different.
[Inaudible] Bill Bailey,
Sore is Sara, right.
So let's have a look at how
the lyrics go on this one,
and I'm going to sing you
the first versus and chorus.
In fact, I'm just going to
sing it to you, I think.
[ Singing ]
Everyone. Oh Sore-gitl.
Come home.
You're being so embarrassing
there.
Gallivanting with all the boys.
Gallivanting with all the guys.
You know, Sore-gitl,
they're all looking
at you and laughing at you.
You know, Sore-gitl,
they're looking
at us and laughing at us.
Oh, you know Sore-gitl
they're all looking
at me and laughing at me.
[ Singing ]
Won't you come home, Sore-gitl.
Won't you come home.
You know, I'm not
that kind of lad.
Listen to what I tell you.
Hear from my tone.
It all does along
when I get so sad.
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
So we have here a performance of
a chap looking frightfully silly
on the stage, and the
question that we have
to ask then is why is Norger
[phonetic] who wrote this song
and performing this song doing
something that makes him look
so silly on the stage.
And the music hall is really
about cathartic experience.
It's about people
laughing and people crying
and people being able
to get their emotions
out when they're living in a
situation that's actually very,
very difficult, that's
struggling to make ends meet.
So let's have a look at
what might be the cathartic
experiences for the
men in the audience
and for the women
in the audience.
So a man comes over
from Eastern Europe,
and he can't keep
his family there.
They haven't got enough to eat.
They come over to London
or indeed to New York,
but to London, and they still
can't make ends meet in London.
So they, the wife also
brings work in at home,
and they still come, and they
bring in a lodger, a boarder,
to help pay the rent, and
they're still not making enough.
They're really struggling
just to make ends meet.
And so the man, who is the wager
earner and the bread winner,
is feeling like his position
as head of the household is
in danger, that he is like
no longer the patriarch
as he can't actually do what the
head of the household is meant
to do, which is to be
able to feed his children.
And then he comes to the music
hall, and he sees someone
on stage who is so much
more pathetic than he is.
And he laughs.
And what about women?
So women come to the music hall,
and they're working
extremely hard,
and they're keeping
the household,
and they're looking
after the children.
And they come to the music halls
and they see a woman
gallivanting with other chaps
and wandering around
London city,
and they go [foreign language
spoken], if only, I had the time
to have an affair with someone.
So, we're setting up a situation
where people can feel something,
and it gives us a sense of
this is not just mimicking the
English musical, but it's
saying something very specific
about the immigrants'
experience.
Okay, so I'm going to move
now to the theme of religion.
And everybody is
writing about religion.
The socialists are
either haranguing religion
or they're using religious
structures to make lots
of points about socialism.
The music hall is making sort
of really quite moving points
about people becoming
more secular
and losing their
connection to religion
and the [inaudible]
writers, the satirists,
are having field days around it.
So, I'm going to have a look
at two texts around this.
So, the first text is by a
guy called Avrom Margolin,
Dr. Avrom Margolin, who is
the editor of Der blofer,
but he was actually a
doctor, a medical doctor.
And he wrote something
called A pekl neviyes.
Now the connection with religion
is a little bit tangential,
but we'll see.
A pekl neviyes means a bunch
of prophesies or a bundle
of prophesies, and it's based
on a chapter from Ezekiel,
which describes the
war to end all wars,
and it starts off like this.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
So he sets up there's
something terrible going
to happen in White Chapel.
There's going to be a
war to end all wars.
So let's have a look at what
that war was going to be.
And he continues
his 166-line stanza
which has 18 people
in the community.
We have the chief
rabbi, Herman Adler.
We have a whole range of people.
We have [inaudible]
my list of them.
We have a 66-line stanza
with all these people on it,
with the chief rabbi, with the
Zionist Ahada Ahm [phonetic],
with the anarchist
leader Rudolf Rocker,
and it tells them what will
happen to all these people
at the end of time when White
Chapels turns upside down.
So the chief rabbi will
stand down and questions
and rulings will be taken to
the secular Zionist Ahada Ahm.
Anarchist leader Rudulf Rocker
will become an inspector
of kosher meat.
The main Yiddish play
[inaudible] are expressed
in the Yiddish [inaudible]
would switch to English,
and the new editor would be
Winston Churchill and so on.
So it's a big satire.
Now what connection this
has to religion, as I say,
it's pretty tangential, but
what it's doing is it's using a
structure and it's saying
really that, first of all,
it's saying it's belittling the
tone of the Ezekiel [inaudible]
but it's also, if you like,
saying that if you use a tone
like that on these silly
little happenings happening
in White Chapel, then
White Chapel is already
such a topsy-turvy place where
everything is going wrong,
there should really be a war to
end all wars to turn it right.
But finally, I'm going to
finish on one more musical song.
And this is a musical song by
Nager, and people use religion
in lots of different ways,
but this is a particularly
interesting use of it
because in the musical you
have a mixture of people who go
to the music hall,
they're not all atheists
like the socialists.
Possibly very few of
them are, in fact.
Some of them have
become secular.
A lot of them would have had
a real feeling of nostalgia
for religion and would have
had a real feeling of loss,
and so what they did in the
musical was they did two things.
They sort of engaged with
that loss at the same time
as making fun, but also engaging
with the fact that the religion
that the immigrants have was
very different to the religion
that the Anglo-Jews had and
that they couldn't connect.
So, I'll just have a look
at the first verse of this
and then sing a couple
of verses of it,
and hopefully you're
going to join in.
Because this song called
Freg kayn katshanes,
in a nice [inaudible] accent,
really Freg nit kayn katshanes,
as in Anglan, Don't Ask Silly
Questions, this is England.
So we'll have a look
at the chorus.
So it goes freg kayn katshanes,
and you have to all do
in your best football sort
of like, football sort
of way go, es iz England.
Okay, shall we try that.
And freg nit kayn
katshanes, es iz England.
Vos toyg mir di tanes,
es iz England.
A medinele a shmatinke,
oy vey size tatinke.
Ales is kapoyer do geshtelt.
And you have to put your hand
in the air and go England.
Right. England.
Freg nit kayn katshanes, es iz
England [singing] es iz England.
A medinele mit minhugimlekh.
Un modne menshelekh, bekitser,
bekitser s'iz a lebedike velt.
So we now get a view of
a man with his hat on
and his [inaudible] and his
beard, and he comes over here
and he says, I thought it was
going to be religious in England
but what happens is
it's just too difficult.
The religion sort of like
doesn't fit in with English life
because if you have to work, you
have to be in the sweat shops.
There's no where to pray.
You're praying there,
and you have
to often be there
on the Sabbath.
And the second character that
we have is we have his neighbor
who is already an Anglicized
Jew, and his neighbor is saying,
no, you know, you can't even
expect that es iz England.
So we'll have a look at the
second and third verses.
[ Singing ]
And, freg nit kayn
katshanes, es iz England.
Vos toyg mir di tanes,
es iz England.
A medinele a shmatinke,
oy vey size tatinke.
Ales is kapoyer do geshtelt.
England. Freg nit kayn
katshanes, es iz England.
Es iz England.
A medinele mit minhugimlekh.
Un modne menshelekh, bekitser,
bekitser s'iz a lebedike velt.
[ Singing ]
And then we have the
neighbor again repeating it,
come on, this is England.
So you see, the nature
of what's happening
to religion is brought up, and
I guess the way it brings it
up both by making fun
of it and treating it
in a more serious way is sort
of shows the double things
that are going on for people.
Maybe they move their
religion because they're having
to work all the time
and [inaudible]
and maybe they feel a
little bit guilty about it.
You've got a lot
of varying degrees
of what people are
feeling about it.
So, this has been a tiny
little glimpse of what you got.
There are a hundred
texts analyzed or looked
at in the book that engage
with British culture.
During that time, I found 300
texts, and all these texts are
in rhyming couplets,
and it's an archive
that has barely been touched,
and as any Yiddish [inaudible]
will tell you here in the states
as well, that there's a huge
archive here in America as well,
and again, the sort of research
that has been done on it is only
like touching the surface
of it, and that, you know,
there's lots and
lots more to do.
So a lot of encouragement
for people, please,
to become Yiddish and
do some of this research
because the social histories
they give us are very real
or very interesting, and
there are lots and lots
of connections, both
with Jewish immigrants
in just different places and
with immigrant culture in London
between the different,
or but in other places,
between the different immigrant
communities in those places.
So I feel that this sort of work
actually does lay the ground
work for a lot of
other things to come.
And thank you for being
a lovely audience.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, so are there
any questions?
Yeah?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Oh, well that's very,
very interesting,
because I haven't heard
what you just told me now.
So, first of all der blofer.
The word blofer in Yiddish
has got a stronger meaning
than in English.
So the word blofer is
like to hoodwink someone.
It doesn't have the same clout.
Now, sometimes it's used gently,
but actually blofer
means cheating and lying.
So, yeah, it's a bad thing.
And I mean a pretty
bad thing in English,
but it's got a gentler
side to it.
But in Yiddish it's
not a nice thing.
And der blofer the
magazine had a byline
which read [foreign language
spoken], everyone lies,
[foreign language spoken].
The blofer comes
to tell the truth.
And so it's very
curious, you saying,
because obviously a blofer
can't really tell the truth,
they're bluffing people, so
it's sort of saying like, okay,
so we're now going
to have double bluffs
and triple bluffs going on here.
But the nature of that magazine
was to expose hypocrisy,
and in fact, there's a very
interesting column that happens
on a number of issues called
[foreign language spoken],
the blofer laughed.
And what it does is it picks
out all these instances
of hypocrisy, and then the
blofer goes ah ha ha ha ha.
And throws his head
back and laughs.
So, the instances of hypocrisy
might be someone is getting
married and the people in the
family go to Eastern Europe,
bring their wife
over and bring her
to the [foreign language
spoken].
Or the blofer is saying, what
you get a sense of in this,
so that's [inaudible]
that's generic yeah,
but then you get the blofer
talking about a certain lord
who will pay his coachman,
his non-Jewish coachman,
substantial bonuses but will
not support a Jewish hospital.
And this was a particular story.
Maybe not that he was paying
his non-Jewish coachman service,
but was saying that he won't
support Jewish things even
thought he is a Jew,
Lord Rothchild,
but he will support
non-Jewish things because he was
so terrified of anti-Semitism
that he was, or the situation
of Jews in England, that
he would sort of fall
over backwards not to
support Jews was what this
statement said.
And the blofer is laughing.
So, they're making fun of things
that are real in the community,
and they're making
fun of generic things.
So, yes, the concept of
blofer, being a blofer,
I think is really, really
important, and I get the sense
that there's a huge amount of
satire being written in Yiddish,
and in a way, satire is trying
to do that, is trying to show
where the hypocrisy
lies, is trying to show
where people are being too
[inaudible] and double minded
and saying one thing
and doing another.
And so it's coming up
over and over again.
So I think it's very
interesting that you say
that England is being seen
as the land of hypocrisy,
and certainly the Yiddish
satirists are pushing, you know,
trying to show where that is.
In fact, even in very
interesting stuff in the '40s
and '50s, they're still
writing Yiddish satire.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
All right.
So there's different publishers
for all these different
things, yeah.
So the socialist publishers,
they are producing
their own presses,
because they really
can't get anyone else
to publish their material.
So they're getting their press,
they've got, for example,
the [foreign language spoken],
which was the main
socialist paper,
was being published
by their own press.
Then it would get defaced,
and people would break in
and smash the printing presses
and they'd have to
like get new ones.
So that's what's
happening there.
So what that shows and what we
write about is there's loads
of politics around publishing.
Then, the more mainstream
papers are also having their
own presses.
The smaller things, so
the socialist pamphlets
and stuff are also
being published
by the [foreign language
spoken] press.
So all of that is in one place.
The Song Book, there are a
number of different publishers.
So there's a publisher
called Mazin [phonetic].
There's a publisher
called Josef [phonetic].
There's a publisher called
Wooderman [phonetic].
And they're all producing
song sheets.
And they're selling them
sort of for a penny.
And then Josef the
publisher, in fact,
there's another song called
[foreign language spoken],
which was what we saw earlier,
and he uses that to advertise
his publishing services
for songs, and he says, I've
go this great, new invention.
I've got a song book,
not just a song sheet,
and he's connecting all of these
and putting them into a book.
So, these people are realizing
there's a commercial market
out there, okay.
So there's the song sheets
that people get for a penny,
but if you do it in a
book, you get even more,
and they're putting
little pictures
of people's faces on them.
So they're really
playing to the market.
And I guess that what's
happening quite a lot is a lot
of these publications will run
for quite short lengths of time
because financially it's really
hard to keep them viable.
So you've got lots of
competing presses and small ones
and slightly larger ones.
The thing about like
Mazin, so ones, and Josef,
the ones who are
producing the song sheets,
on one side they're
producing these song sheets.
On the other side they're
producing like Zionist songs
about sort of the new Zionist
movements that produces,
for example, Josef produces
a series of songs to the tune
of [foreign language
spoken] in Yiddish.
A and then also they're
producing religious stuff
as well.
So, I mean I find it sort
of like quite strange
that at the same time this
publisher is producing these
silly sexy musical lyrics
and then also producing some
quite religious material.
But that's what's happening.
There are a number of
publishers doing that.
Yes?
Well, I mean it's interesting
because [inaudible] has always
tried to be quite trendy,
and so it's set in the present
time, but it is in the east end,
so it is in this area or a
little bit further east maybe.
The trendiness has meant
that it has sort of brought
in immigrants occasionally
because [inaudible] it was
like a very much a non-immigrant
population as it was engaging
with sort of the white east
enders who had been born there
and had lived there
for generations.
But it's certainly in this area,
and so it's engaging with some
of the issues around work.
And I think it's interesting you
bring that up, because in a way,
I think it became very popular
because the east end has been
home to all sorts of waves
of immigrants as they came
in and then often they moved
out as they became
more upwardly mobile.
So the here were the
Irish before the Jews
and then the Jews, and then
we've had Banglandeshian,
Somolian.
And so it's become an
area that has been sort
of an immigrant area as well
as an indigenous population
of white British people.
So there's a sort of
sentimentalism that goes
with the east end
and that has sort
of like been drawn around it.
And I think that in a
way that's why something
like east enders has got such a,
just by its title has got quite
a powerful resonance for people.
>> Sharon Horowitz: My friend,
Jane Petzler [phonetic] has done
research on the little booklets.
>> Vivi Lachs: Yep.
>> Sharon Horowitz:
I find it ridiculous
that people would sing
along with the performers.
I mean if I was a performer,
I don't think I would like it.
But anyways, so she's done--
>> Vivi Lachs: Yep.
>> Sharon Horowitz: [Inaudible]
was a publisher [inaudible]
but anyways, she was able to
find a lot of these booklets.
Many of them she found in
the Library [inaudible].
>> Vivi Lachs: Oh really!
I didn't know that.
>> Sharon Horowitz: Apparently
they sent them to the Library.
They were unopened, but
of course she found them.
They allowed her to open them.
>> Vivi Lachs: Wow.
>> Sharon Horowitz: But
anyway, I just was going
to mention that's also an
American musical things,
these little booklets
[inaudible].
>> Vivi Lachs: She's fantastic.
Jane Petzler has done
like wonderful work
in collecting a huge
number of American musicals,
and what people now need to do
with her work is to have a look
at some of the social
histories that come from them,
but she's done a fantastic
job of bringing them to life.
>> Sharon Horowitz: Great,
anyway, thank you very much
and thank you all for coming.
[ Applause ]